this is a data of warning watching this
video on your phone may suck up your
precious pricy mobile data this is not a
test this is not a test okay maybe a bit
dramatic but don't tell me you haven't
gotten a text from your carrier lately
warning that you're getting awfully
close to that data limit and according
to a recent report it can blame the fact
that we're watching more and more videos
on our phones yep
like this one but hey don't blame me
blame the carriers and the apps that
don't warn you last month
I nearly had to pay Verizon overages
because I didn't realize snapchat was
such a hog so I've cut down drastically
by making small adjustments welcome to
my data diet step 1
pinpoint the biggest data hogs and then
enable data savers you can see which
apps use the most data through tools in
iOS and Android Android can
automatically clear the amount used when
your billing cycle is over on the iPhone
you have to manually reset it
unsurprisingly snapchat Facebook and
Safari suck up most of my data then it
was time to roll up my sleeves I enabled
snapchats travel mode to stop it from
immediately loading all videos while on
mobile data and Facebook and Twitter I
disabled auto playing videos unlike
Chrome and opera Safari doesn't have a
data saver mode which compresses images
and video check this out in Safari
loading a site used five megabytes in
Chrome and opera mini half the data was
used with data savers turned on Opera
Mini helps with video - watching a three
minute 720p video in Safari used 64
megabytes in Opera Mini only 23 sure the
compressed video doesn't look as good
but I don't need an IMAX on my phone
number two I'm gonna let you in on a not
so well kept secret carriers are
desperate to keep you right now so take
advantage of all they offer or consider
switching Verizon recently ran a two
gigabyte giveaway sprint just undercut
some of t-mobile's data pricing by 50%
but at t-mobile one gigabyte can still
go further than most
with its new binge on service all video
is downscale to 480p resolution to save
data streaming a five-minute SNL clip
used 40 megabytes of data on t-mobile
but 60 megabytes on Verizon step 3
Wi-Fi Wi-Fi Wi-Fi unless you have an
unlimited data plan you should just wait
to watch those long videos on Wi-Fi it
also may be worth signing up for a Wi-Fi
subscription like Boeing goes
it's cheaper than mobile data and Wi-Fi
hotspots with pass point automatically
log you in when they're in range you can
also use an app like Wi-Fi map to find
nearby hotspots follow the plan and your
data will last you long enough to finish
this video